okay so what I'd like you to do I've got
this question up on the board how do you
make decisions and difficult ethical
situations and you guys have been in
song all that Yvette engine cases where
you weren't quite sure what the right
thing was to do but eventually did
something you figured something right
you may have been tempted to do
something and it was wrong or you
actually got into a horrible out on
where it seemed like no matter what he
did you were you were doing the wrong
thing and you really wanted to do the
right thing but you couldn't see your
way out think for a couple minutes well
now that's just a few moments actually
about what you at present I'm not saying
what you want to rely on I'm interested
in what you actually do rely how do you
make these decisions and I'd like you to
write down just treat this so think
about Cass decisions in a important ones
right and what went into that write down
three resources i don't mean resources
like you went and looked it up in the
library or something like that I mean
like anything that helped you anything
that you found helped you resolve that
situation
there's a reason we're doing this would
you
then what we're going to do is we'll
just pick people randomly tell me what
your three are and as we go through them
I would also like to see who has things
similar so if they say something I've
cleared up and raise your hand if you
get something along the same sort of
lines so if they say feelings you put
down emotions or desires you'd raised
right so let's start with how many of
you had something like that okay call it
was actually do it yeah oh yeah anything
like feelings or emotions did anyone
have something like gut feelings or you
just have kind of hunch or anything like
that we found the hunch or okay
intuition yeah you have sort of sense
about things and you can't articulate it
that well sometimes that's reliance
there's a little bit of a digression but
all you know I used to teach you to
maximum security prison right and some
of the people there are really bad
people and some of people
are you know more or less in between and
they've done some bad things than some
of them are actually quite good people
because they have changed over time in
prison and there are certain people who
creep you out you know the feeling that
you get being with some people and you
can tell there's something really off
you should not trust this person you
should not do anything with this person
you should trust that unless you have it
for everybody in which case they've got
a psychological problem but in most
cases you should trust that Plus that
does it actually tend to be fairly
reliable the other case would be if you
if you find yourself only feeling that's
where its people to serve race or
certain class or nationally then you've
probably got a science problem right but
if you're feeling it in its just sort of
popping up don't walk down the dark
alley with that person I'll go home with
that person because your intuition often
does tell you when something's wrong
well what's up acid frown ask for help
okay so that other people other people
have their ideas how many of you had
something like that consulting at Wow
almost everybody that's pretty good this
time p a crook did you have any other
ones you saw our ministry no really I
had like listen to music and think about
it but that's kind of play comfortably
that's kind of an interesting one listen
to music and think of
so what is listening to the music before
I'm just focus on something else so you
can't anything let's call that let's
broaden it will call that practices for
focusing or maybe relax sometimes you
need to like declutter that's it could
be music some people do that with
meditation or prayer some people you
know we've got this metaphor go to your
safe place inside your head My dear
waterfall or I'm for us or something
like that but if that helps you that
could be a resource right when you said
music I actually thought you know a lot
of people get their ideas about about
things from songs which probably is a
great idea they are love songs
there I promise of love songs that are
helpful in making ethical decisions but
most of them are probably the studio are
you know I love it so much so even
though you through treat me bad i'm
always going to be there for you you
know not because you know that's the
right thing to do because i need you so
bad baby you know that is that it's that
a quick good way to behave sounds good
when you put you know a whole bunch of
instruments behind it somebody's a great
voice but is that a reliable guide for
running a life problem so what else do
you guys yeah like values are values ok
there's broad thing values what do you
mean by beliefs like that is long like
leaves like you know you don't do
something because you believe it's wrong
or okay so like let's say on like me my
friends are I don't know it's a fighting
over a girl I don't got belief that I
don't you know get involved with girl
but I was that my friends are talking to
so that's like my personal belief okay
so that's the you're talking about there
something like rule yeah you get
anything expressive such I if my friends
are involved with a girl I'm not going
to mess with her
right that's something you can express
as a sort of principle okay so this is a
good list we've also had anything like
that like believe principal value
anybody hope some of you did know what
were some the other things that you guys
got that worn out here so far oh that's
good yeah so not just like looking ahead
at the past experience how things panned
out before learning learning lessons
very best thing to do with painful
things like that is to learn other
people's lessons by the dirts watching
them but often you know we have to learn
through our own failures I'll give you
an example few minutes personal example
any any other things think of me of I
subjects
that's interesting how should we express
that so that these are actually these 24
very interesting because later on this
semester we're going to talk about the
world theory from utilitarianism and
Tillett Arianism holds that the way that
you should make ethical decisions is you
should think about outcomes and pick the
outcome that is best for all the people
involved as much as you can so I mean
there are some things that it will go
along with what if I could impose
horrible pain one person in this
classroom and all the rest of us would
really you know get a lot of pleasure
out of that utilitarianism to say we're
all the bit of the many ways the good of
the the one or the fuse so that's okay
there are some problems with that but
this idea of looking to not just
yourself think about specific case and
egoism you know you don't just look at
yourself you look at all the people that
are involved that's that's an ethical
principle that that is part of the mall
theory this notion of thinking how it
would be not such as yourself but if
somebody else would do it that's another
moral principle or rule to guide you
yeah that's pretty good one you know
later on we're going to look at guiding
them on
times and is his moral theories called a
ontology and partisans was it's about
universalization can you universalize
can you say well not just in my case but
in everybody else's case they should act
this way so if you can give the advice
to somebody well you should behave this
way because it would be good thing for
you to do in those situations and you
take yourself out of interest which I
take it is what you're talking about
here you're already sort of taking on a
portion okay so you've got all these
different things and how do you actually
make decisions in real cases if you have
a lot of time to think about it you may
bring a lot of things to bear sometimes
you have to make your decisions right
away and that could be you know good or
bad depending on how well prepared you
are for making those decisions one of
the things that we didn't put up here I
think you don't think about it that
often is you know this notion of the
virtues your character your your habits
your disposition to instance and those
could involve these and those could
require you to do some of these things
that you could have had always looking
at how it affects everybody else or
thinking about how it would be if it
wasn't you doing is it somebody else did
it you might also have a habit of just
relying on your inner feelings sometimes
your feelings can actually be good guys
sometimes they're not I think you all
right
i'll give you my example this play in
this course i used to be a very
aggressive arguer remember how last
class were talking about the person sole
reason and spirited park and the
appetites I i have not had so much of a
problem in my life with the appetites
that you know I eat too much but that's
it's been an experiment part of the soul
you know that person wants to get on the
part the part that wants to be better
than everybody else the part that gets
angry yeah I would be very angry when
our arguments and would actually I was
very good at argument you know I have a
good intellect and but I used it in
wrong place and so I heard a lot of
people I actually drove one graduate
student away from considering the school
that I was yeah I was so fast when it
came to that they actually coined a verb
to Seattle her eyes which meant to get
into an argument with somebody and just
totally you know go after the throat and
demolish them and you know what got me
to stop doing this you know people
started telling me you're a jerk when it
comes in and deciding how to argue with
somebody that's a decision you don't
have to do that I don't have to do that
I could you know justify it and say
things like well I'm pursue the truth
and you know if they can't stand up to
it than them then they really shouldn't
be doing philosophy anyway you can
always come up with lots of
justification can't you for any sort of
things you want to do question is are
they actually good
vacations and what actually ended up
doing it for me was feelings emotions
realizing that you know I was affecting
other people there were so they're just
looking at the good of other people
involved but I felt bad you know that
that's that regret that you have after
making a bad decision that can sometimes
be a very good guy you could also have
brick wrapped for the wrong thing so
don't people do that don't think so the
motion may not be the best but it can be
sometimes other people other people are
kind of sounding for if other people are
you telling you you're a jerk and they
do it consistently you probably should
look at your behavior right if they're
telling you that you're doing the right
thing maybe some of them are flattering
you it all sorts of very right metaphors
for that sort of thing do you know what
I'm talking about maybe sometimes it's
just but but a lot of times other people
are a good way of tongue what we need to
do radio is really going to be much more
interested in this drama Valley he's
going to think that those and the
virtues put all these other things into
perspective so this brings us to this
allegory of the cave and to go back to
something that we looked at earlier the
semester you remember when we read
Alistair McIntyre that first essay a lot
of you know found kind of difficult
right because there's a lot of material
there one of the things that you might
have passed over
talking about stories he was saying all
of you have a story right you're still
developing your story and our stories
that's acceptable your stories intersect
with your of your classmates but we all
have different stories and then he says
there's certain stories that everybody
should read and they're not your story
yet until you read them and you
assimilate them and maybe you have
conserved back-and-forth conversation
with that's true and he talks about
different things I first sack he's got a
thing for things Irish so he's got some
Irish stories in there and I think he
had the Iliad well this story about the
cave this is one of those stories this
is one of those those things that you
should run into during college because
it's part of the liberal arts education
I helped you figure out what are you
actually doing what's the point of
being here in Palo that you're doing all
this sudden wait you're preparing for
careers that's important right some of
you are here because you know you're
training your body you're doing
athletics who are benefiting the college
some of you are here because you know
just genuinely enjoy learning and you
did well in high school and you said I
on I'm going to go to college take some
classes and I'm not going to take the
classes that they all told me I have to
take in high school I take what I will
stick right but what is the purpose
what's the larger purpose for you to
become educated and so you can ask you
something what does that mean what is
the process of Education this is where
this allegory of the cave is a very
powerful story and what's an elegant an
allegory sort of like a para it is a
story we can't story this supposed to be
realistic
is it like a case file in case of this
Ram such and such more on this day it's
not like that it's a and when we use
this term metaphor what we mean is it's
not literally true but it's revealing
something to us that may be true on a
deeper level so if I stay when a class
is that for if I haven't had my coffee
i'm a real bear in the morning I'm not
hairy lips or you know big and strong
and I don't have a huge teeth sort of
feral instinct to Ruth things apart but
you understand what I'm saying what I I
say that because I can have this thing
that I need to keep you going I'm bear
what does it mean means that I'm
irritable your rationale may be clumsy
event you know there's enough or not you
know you don't have bears doing
precision work right there made me for
doing big things well on a deeper level
that that's true now think about the
parables think about stories that you've
heard from mr. that thing in the Bible
right I used to teach Religious Studies
classes and then have these students
because I teaching a whole Testament New
Testament this is back in the prison and
they would say stuff like you know where
did King get his wife from you know
there's just Adam and Eve and and you
know Cain and Abel and Cain kills Abel
this is before they have another kid and
King has to go off somewhere we got this
mark out of God's mad ass and canes
worried about somebody else killing
who's going to kill them yeah well you
know these stories were not intended to
be a genealogy of everybody in the
universe there's there's no there's no
line of the story that says an adam and
eve or the only people in existence at
the site it just doesn't tell you about
that right some people have concluded
that well everything important must be
in that story but that's more of an
allegory it's telling a story that's
supposed to be about a metaphor about
what the this is actually the case for
the allegory of the cave and with Cain
and Abel story about the human condition
ok a naval story it's got a lot of rich
ideas too you know kane says things like
am I my brother's keeper and people
still say that for this day and what are
you know why does that have these
residences because the story is a
powerful story cain is worried about
people doing him it why because he took
life themselves there's some sort of
general idea there one of the other
things to think about too this was going
to be on
class but in this sort of biblical you
know judeo-christian understanding of
the version of human beings what's the
what's the first way people die murder
at the hands of another human being so
really early on well you know is this
supposed to be a roadmap for every
single person's life you know mapped out
in great detail no it's now same thing
with the allegory of the cave what's
what's going on the allegory of the cave
we've got this cave and what do we have
this somebody said it prisoners right
there change it any of you look at those
videos that I post it like the
claymation one if you want to see what
this would actually look like I found
some things on use where some people
actually spent the time to make a
claymation of the allegory of the cave
minutes it's actually pretty good
there's so few other ones that I put in
there some of them are not quite so good
but you know they made an effort so
their Christmas and does it tell us what
they eat
does it tell us you know what there's
leasing arrangements are no what do we
know
what does it tell us
okay so there's there's a fire above and
behind them right why why why campus
well they don't but it's because they
can't see what's behind them because
they're they're chained so imagine
people that are chained like this and
looking up at the wall and you know
there's some problems here how would
they eat what they go to the bathroom
you know no but they had an itch we're
not worried about that sort of thing
right because I got to the other what do
they watch there's a fire you're right
and what's he happening behind them
what's up you said something that's on
the right track something like said
right shadows in front of them there's
people behind them they're bringing you
know things that cast shadows ya know
who are these people behind them well
that's not explain everything we sort of
speculate about that later on once we
get the base
so they're looking at these shadows in
front of them and they're all chained
together so they're talking with each
other hey what about that thing Hey look
you know that shadow is killing that
show that shadows pursuing you know
power the shadow is eating those two
shadows are are you know getting it on
all sorts of things right they can't see
themselves that way yeah this is take
some imagination why couldn't me just
turn your heads and look at sutter see
them well they don't look like shadows
well this is this part of the story man
so if the answers all they're seeing is
what's in front and it seems to that
very real why does it seem to the real
it's the only thing they know you know
if you if you grew up in the countryside
you know and you actually pay attention
not just somebody living in the country
watches TV all the time and you go
outside you get to know an awful lot
about soil and trees and win the weather
and different kinds of grass and what
they're good for and what not to touch
you want to touch and how the animals
move and all that sort of stuff if
you're living in the city you may
experience some of that part but the
park is not that that much like that
we're thinking about this great mastered
River Hudson as far as we know you can
swim the Hudson right that's a big river
is that like going swimming in your
swimming pool you experience something
quite different for you if you don't in
there I don't think I tried to swim
across especially this time
what's that it's a little slow well it's
not only long Struthers there's all
sorts of currents and Eddie's and could
be a little bit unpredictable you learn
about these things by by your experience
them and if your only experience is very
narrow that's all you one else and our
tendency is to assume that what we know
what we experience is the whole of
reality now what happens to this prison
for somebody inexplicable reason
somebody comes along princess chains as
the dragon.lock or her up could be could
be all right it dragged them up to the
outside how do things go that are you
happy about that
very good yeah you you all have the
experience of going into a dark room for
quite a while maybe some of you who
played too much video games and stay
inside and don't have a clock I remember
I had this friend who get his own
computer this they still nuts you're
still my friend solutions instance but
he had an office and it was in the
middle of this factory no windows or
anything like that and he didn't have a
clock in there and we would go in there
and this is what I was about we know 19
20 21 the end we would play videos now
if you don't have a clock and you don't
have any way of telling times you can
sit there and play games for 24 hours
straight if the game is engaging you can
come out you know a couple days later
and you stumble out totally gross
because you're showered for you know 36
hours or so and you the Sun hits you and
it's like spike in your head or you know
think about being homo if any of you
have experience being on waking up the
next morning everything sounds so
intense lights are so bright that's
what's happening with this guy this guy
has never that outside the cave so this
is actually much worse let me breathe
something so he says
at first when any of that was liberated
and compelled suddenly to stand up and
turn his neck round Loggins look towards
the light will sheffer sir sharp pains
he will be unable to see the realities
of which in his former state he saw the
shadows so when he sees the stuff
happening up there the fire not he's not
going to be able to make any sense of
that another dragon further up I was
high he's never been outside he's never
seen real things he's only seen the
facsimile the duplicates and it shatters
the images of them yeah his instructor
is pointing to the objects as they pass
and acquiring him to name them he can't
name a thing I don't know what that is I
don't know what you're doing well the
hell are you why are you bothering me
like this let me go back down to people
if you make him look at the the wise
he's not going to see it so what do you
go through a process almost like
rehabilitation and you know we do
step-by-step stuff for your body we do
it for the mind we do it for the psyche
you know your your emotions if you want
to change that attitude is or things
like that you can't change it all at
once what is this getting she starts out
looking at what's easiest to see
reflections
she's not looking at the Sun itself he's
not looking at the things themselves
once his eyes get stronger which they
will do provided you know they're not to
damage he can start looking at actual
things then eventually you can actually
start looking at the Sun itself and this
is a huge game for him and imagine going
from kenosha shadows two-dimensional
things kind of puppet things to the real
world think about you know when you've
got great experience in your life where
something came along and it took a
little while for you to get the hang of
that but it changed what you saw and I
knew how you viewed things and it was
like a revelation to you and once you
get your head around it a whole world
what have you guys experienced maybe I
think you know that's me too crude or
anything like that but I'll tell you one
that all of you experience you must
security right and in puberty and you
were you know your boys and girls on you
were aware of the difference between
boys and girls and you knew something
about the anatomy and all that and then
suddenly you were flooded with all these
hormones and they making you don't do
things like grow and get here you know
voice deep in or you know grow certain
ways and all that but it also get a very
intense fields right start having much
more attachments attractions
embarrassments all these sorts of things
your world opened up by becoming aware
of the mystery of sexuality now that's
just a bottling thing I mean it does
involve mental spiritual right think of
this now in terms of an even greater
awakening that's what's happening with
this guy what happens that so now he's
very happy that's not where the story
hansel is what happens next
do you stay out there yeah
like they can't believe they don't like
yeah you're right look already the
section says they're in the habit of
conferring honors among themselves on
those who are quickest to observe the
passing shadows and remark which the one
before was followed after he can't
compete with them right because his eyes
are used to real stuff and they're used
to looking at this is based on which is
hard to see yeah says madden want such a
one coming suddenly out of the Sun to be
replaced from his old situation would it
not be certain of his eyes full of
darkness you could you know you go from
the full sunlight into we developed on
this full sunlight into a dark room you
can't see anything and if you stay in
there long enough your eyes will adjust
again and you'll be able to make things
out but when he makes things out there
going to seem very different data there
he's not going to be having as much fun
looking at the images because he knows
they're fake she knows that they're not
as good as the things that are aware
outside and then it says if there was a
contest that he had competed measuring
the shadows of the prisoners who'd never
moved out of the death while the site
was still week before his eyes have
become steady would he not be ridiculous
ridiculous means laughable somebody
who's worthy of being made fun of men
would say of him that up he went and
down he came without his eyes and that
it was better not to even think of
ascending if anyone tried to lose
another
them up to the light they would put him
to death because you know in their view
is that this doesn't make sense doesn't
good luscious good practical reason if
you if you see somebody doing something
well it let's take for example in our
society and many other societies what we
call psychotropic drugs are are
controlled substances and some of the
people who are really big um things like
LSD here AOE oh man opened up a whole
world to me i could like smell colors
and all the sort of stuff in and it's
got my generation a lot of a lot of my
friends because I hung out with all the
burnouts used gross with drugs and they
would tell me about their experiences
and you know one of the reasons i never
used that sort of stuff is I didn't find
their descriptions really that
interesting I would say so he smell
colors ok but some of them you know some
other people would say but I'll walk
along you see all these the rainbows and
things like that the bad things can do I
need a girlfriend who had a bad trip and
for for a long time she saw wolves
coming out of the walls to eat her I
mean that you never took that's them
again you know smart other people would
say though and this is back in the
generation before mine oh if it opens up
your mind so you can perceive reality as
it really is now we can have a
metaphysical debate about whether that
actually takes place let's say it's not
actually the case let's say that what's
happened was just a bunch of neurons
firing in your head making a great color
jump and that if you do it off if it
burns your brain out which is actually
true well then there's probably a good
reason for making us legal right which
is what they do if you think that that's
the case then you should probably make
it illegal if you think that doing
philosophy makes people in diverse
people that if somebody wants to propose
having all of your study philosophy you
should hang them or run them out of town
doesn't that make sense I mean I don't
think that it really opens your mind
uptown everything really is but even if
you do drawing or something it doesn't
open your mind it just gives you a
different perspective that made never
thought of yeah you know a lot of time
yes probably folia see you gorgeous
melancholy be so but if you have a
different perspective on something they
don't give you a new idea about
something yeah you know I don't want to
go into a long thing about drugs well no
but classified existed jars incidentally
if you didn't be prospective well i was
thinking about like say ecstasy ecstasy
was originally developed in order to
facilitate psychological and then i got
why do people take ecstasy at raves and
parties and stuff like that because it
makes people more open to physical
sensations and it mellows their moved
out so they're more willing to hang out
with a bunch of strangers who they don't
know until that day and have a good time
and maybe that could actually open your
path to having two experiences I mean if
you're kind of a closed in person I'm
not suggesting anybody taking ecstasy
one makes that very clear I'm just
speaking hypothetically if you were kind
of a closed in person as you went to
some party and you weren't having a good
time because you feel like I don't know
anybody here you know I may be taking
ecstasy we open that up and then you'd
find out that you actually have
something in common with these people
who look like a bunch of neon hippies
right now I don't know but you know
there's a lot of things like that you're
right it doesn't have to be drugs it
could be going to anger management class
it could be going fishing with somebody
it could be all sorts of things that why
did you arrange an experience with this
allegory of the cave what we're talking
about Plato's talking about is seeing
realities
they they truly are and what we're
interested in for FX is two things one
is a question let's say that an allegory
of the cave actually holds let's say it
has to do with our condition that were
originally in a state like the cave that
we think we know what we're engaging
with and that only when it comes to
ethics were you know kind of in a model
where we're connecting this situation
where we all talked a lot about this or
the stuff like for instance an execution
that took place last night right we
talked about this a little bit before
class in troy davis on my twitter feed i
didn't use twitter few of you get you
some things more properly right so a lot
of my friends are posting on facebook
wow this is a travesty ethics this
ethics that you know all sorts of people
talking about it and it's kind of
interesting elster McIntyre has noted
that in our society we tend not to talk
about ethics before something happens we
tend to talk about an occasion by
secular circumstances and then everybody
starts sounding off but a lot of that is
just like the shadows in the cave quite
frankly it's not based on any sort of
well-thought-out principles lot of us
just sort of you know got feelings and
people you know being for this is me for
that some people were you know saying
things like death penalty is terrible
you know and then stroke about
corporations I'll believe corporations
are people when Texas starts executing
all this sort of stuff people are
getting very inflamed about this and
somebody else is executed last
I too i mentioned this before I forgot
his name got also forgot the name of his
victim but he's one of the guys who
chained another man behind his pickup
truck and dragged him to the dime and I
didn't see a lot of people protesting
about them but if you know if Troy Davis
is execution is such a terrible thing
it's a sign Bob you shouldn't have
capital punishment all all the stuff you
think that would apply to this case too
but that's not what we see the shadows
on the wall focus on this thing right
here and they don't get into the depth
of them they don't really go into the
like that's my life something somebody
got new story because it was killed us
yeah and that makes for good good news
and but there are innocent people killed
every day all over the place and so why
this this particular case well that's
the shadow that got up on the walls time
around yeah yeah but it's not like us
sure like when you're a peak ago when
your father around what just happened
yeah we're starting to do right here
this is to come out of the cave this is
what Plato cause dialectic where we're
starting to talk about things in terms
of general principles and not just this
case right well wouldn't innocent person
who ever it happens to be is is put to
death something terrible's this is the
state doing it and how does that compare
to a fathered a lot of Socrates does
exactly that sort of thing i'll say
here's a case what would it be like if
we use this example what's it like if we
use this example that helps to pull us
out of the cave where we're just
concerned with the images that are being
thrown at us and we don't have much
control over which images we get placed
in front of us if you know if you think
about this cave thing plato force didn't
know anything about TP didn't existed or
media or anything
we live surrounded by it and that's very
much like a living in the cave that's
why the picture that took an I learn the
allegory of the cave is a bunch of
people sitting around a television and
they all get televisions heads in order
to get out of the kid we have to engage
in dielectric we have to look at general
principles that's part of what we do in
this class and that's part of what if
you want to be making good ethical
decisions somewhere along the line you
have to be able to do you have to be
able to articulate not just how you feel
at this time or how this one case is
this way at this one time but the
broader general principles the Plato has
a whole theory about this which I'm not
going to hear I talked about that in
intro philosophy that I'll be recording
that lecture too so if you're interested
in Plato's theory of the forms so that
sort of stuff that can give you the link
to that as far as the ethics class goes
I don't think we need to worry so much
about about their as about this general
idea that you get out of the cave by
thinking these things through in general
ways by moving away from just your story
remember the McIntyre thing you have
your questions what is my good how do i
achieve that good that's the particular
the universal is what is the good for
human beings and we frame these things
universally when we're doing moral
theory eventually and you go back and
forth right and then you should you're
not existing just go to person outside
of the cave only looking at the
realities themselves I think Plato's a
little bit maybe off in that respect
although you notice here's so here's the
second question he comes back to the
cave shitty
let us think about this in terms of an
actual decision to make let's say this
whole story is true right it's very
pleasant being outside of the Kate
listen you get to see things as they
really are they're beautiful you get to
see a whole new dimension of reality
that was being kept for me before think
about how many of you like music think
about the things you like in music and
imagine having those taken away from you
so that all you hear from now on
whenever your music plays is something
like that you become tone
think about how impoverished your life
would be how many of you listen to music
say at least three hours a day at least
on the background how many of you would
if you had to go several days about
listening music would feel sad so think
about this you know in the allegory of
the cave this guy is seeing things as
they are she's going to go back inside
there and then look at shadows and talk
with people about this right now I'm
only talking about shadows would it be
better for him to stay outside of the
cave some of you are not in your heads
yeah how many feelings out of the cage
like if he likes it out there is she
stayed up there but I don't think it
should I go back inside and some people
they should come up he shouldn't his
[ __ ] it when I because that's the
reality before that and that's like one
big thing but isn't it better to be
exposed you know what's really there if
you're being sued but they don't know
anything else i guess like they are
happy with the yelling okay so you leave
them in there in their ignorance
ignorance is bliss
this but I think you guys should tell
them this is like competitions I'm
really hard so much stuff yeah but like
is better we've ever known and not know
whether we should just know because it
is out there exactly four reasons so why
it's onion like this ok what is you can
be out here out there and explore
education yeah notice in the story he's
motivated not necessarily from sense of
duty but for a sense of pity ya when ya
learn something that's been going on
within the government and in turn
related that everybody yeah it's in the
media kind of situation there before
that case the realization that is a good
thing
your people people are flight you on the
other side of the fence understand yeah
we often talk about it in terms of
empowering people by giving them
information right and it's the
information if the information doesn't
matter them yeah leaving the cable um do
whatever they want if it's stuff that
actually could affect their lives then
maybe maybe it's better to educate me
maybe it's better to lead them out of
the cave certainly if it's athletics if
the way that we tend to do well this is
pretty sloppy and not very good and sort
of you know ad-hoc put together on basis
of whatever we can come up with at the
time which is pretty much yeah for most
people and maybe those who actually have
you know going out of the cave and
studied these things sure Plato one
second Plato actually says you know
nobody actually helped you out of the
cave or you know society didn't help you
out of the cave yeah stay out of the
game how are those people down there you
don't owe them anything now if society
has helped you out of the cave in some
way since your education what education
is the story about education the maybe I
do need to go back in and so there's
ideal city he makes the Guardians go out
of the cane there's a whole class of
people and then he makes them [ __ ]
backings if you can't stay up there we
have to come back down here but notice
they're not they're not going to get to
lead other people out of the cave except
for other Guardians they're coming back
in to help rule within the cave because
they've seen the reality is now they can
make better sense of the shadow so the
shadows are still there it's just now
there's people who can tie against it
that's an action that's actually a
shadow with this and here's what we know
about yeah this going to say yeah pity
maybe you might want to say okay you
know you guys you know might be
interested in checking see what's
outside the cave and stuff but I don't
think he has a moral obligation to try
to convince them of something that they
don't want to do I mean as soon as I
said no we like get in here you're used
to it I mean he can oldest or not there
is it we're gonna kill your [ __ ]
pocket instead they sends it just left
and said all right fun you know I won't
you guys knowing with nice opportunity
yeah by jenny lowe see you later yeah
opportunity work more you can sleep oh
like yeah it's we can be ready and it's
good like to go back and like let them
see what I already like seen but
sometimes like they not like in this
case and like they just wanted to like
be in clearing about it yeah let me let
me change the question up a little bit
let's say you're the prisoner you've
gotten out of the cave you know that if
you go back into the cave you'll only be
able to pull one person allocate the
rest of them are going to stuck there
should you do it is it is it worth it to
do it for just one bring one person
yes good good question if they want
let's say let's make it even tougher
them you don't have it you don't get to
tell them you have to go back in they
might say I just want to stay out of the
cave look at the beautiful realities is
it worth it yeah it's worth because I
mean yeah when they're gonna see the
children back out eighth and got them to
accurately trying to favor pay forward
but it's what if it's like be free right
now what good you don't know what's
they've got it it's on person you know
you can't really trust them because you
see the real question here is is it only
important because we generate this thing
point people off you know one person has
it to another person is 0 or is there
something worthwhile than just getting
out of the cave itself if there is that
any person getting pulled out of the
cave is a good thing I remember I went
through this myself when I was a
graduate student one of my professors
who is very old man who i read Plato
with in Greek so I didn't do it in the
philosophy department into the classes
and I was going through this thing that
a lot of people do you may go through
something like this in your life where
you say okay so I'm going to study all
this stuff so I can somehow make it part
of my life and then I'm going to pass it
on to other people and what's going to
determine whether eyes whether my life
had an invaluable I pass on to other
people but what if they don't pass their
stuff
anybody else or what if nobody wants
what I have to offer you know then I've
just wasted this is a grad school so I
was Bonnie halfway through I just wasted
you know four years of undergrad and
three or four years of graduates will
all be wasting the rest of my life just
one second and what he said to me is
first of all I said I don't through that
myself there's always a good thing to
learn isn't it that somebody else went
through something similar because it
tell you there's a on the other side he
said this is the way I look at it
there's a fire and I'm tending that fire
and if somebody else wants to come warm
yourself by the fire that's good and if
somebody else wants to stay after i'm
done and keep the fire going that's even
better but if nobody does anything and
i'm the only one sitting here by the
fire I still got the fire and I'm doing
the right thing process so by teaching
Plato's in him my teaching play-doh even
if none of my students ever get this is
still worthwhile that's what is it and I
found it very helpful to me that's sort
of like this issue of if you pull
somebody out of cave let's say they
don't go back let's say they say screw
all those other people bunch of dummies
sitting there looking at shadows you
still want a good thing could take them
out of the cave amateur so if you
educate people if you lead them to
become better at the precision
looking at principles even if they don't
pass that on to other people that's not
where the real value is the real value
is getting outside the kick what were
you just base what you're saying though
firing 70 years good you have the same
guy yeah okay I'm going to end with with
that but played out I want to talk a
little bit about Aristotle before we end
this last night so Aristotle was Plato
student all right and what I really
wanted to talk about here is how
different the text is going to be that
you're going into the Nicomachean ethics
from the Republic the Republic was a
dialogue where people are talking back
and forth you've got characters that you
can identify and you've got multiple
sides being presented right and I think
when you were reading the Republic at
least for the first time you may have
had a hard time figuring out who is
saying what yes no and sometimes the
characters would say things and you
would realize afterwards that's not what
they really think yeah get that
experience too they're saying well
you're saying this or Simona nning says
this or somebody says this what I really
think is is this we're even capitalist
you know all their old Madden say this
but here's where they're going wrong
it's a little bit easier with a dialogue
to figure out who's talking and to
distinguish these different points of
view from each other because you've got
characters you can tie into the
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics it's
going to seem very confusing to you the
first time you read it and the second
because hearing to say he jumps all over
the place and flitting from topic to
topic to topic Aristotle will actually
at some points in the text start talking
about one thing and then you move
something else that he'll say coming
back to my point which means that you
actually have to like correlate those
those parts together I'm going to try
and help you with that but you have to
do that as well Aristotle in nikka
McCain ethics book one is going to be
looking at a lot of different viewpoints
on what is the good life what is the
point of doing the things that we do
what is what is the end the concert that
we're pursuing that's going to guide
ethical decision that's going to guide
what we want to do it we have to think
about this carefully but he's not going
to give you the answer right away the
way Aristotle begins and says let's look
at what everybody says but look at the
wide range of possibilities so he's not
going to give you the answer until about
halfway through foot one and then he's
going to clarify its voices and while
happiness happiness is what we're
actually after what's happened well some
people say this some people say this
some people say this and you're gonna
wonder why don't you cut to the chase
Aristotle you know shut up about these
other people and tell us what you
actually think isn't that a reasonable
thing to say to somebody who's going to
talk about you asking a question
so-and-so says this is this you know I
didn't ask you what someone saw said I
asked you what you think that's not the
way I saw the works there's a reason for
them and this may not make sense to you
right off right away I may take a while
for this again why do you look at what
everyone else has to say what I think
forgetful loss was to get out you're
going to buy a car you don't help you
don't just call it a lot
first thing you see hurting your
feelings that's pretty mean I waited by
a car I'll talk with people right who do
you talk to car salesman but they're now
Marley we're trying to sell you
when you talk to you talk to a bunch of
people to get the six did they all see
things the same way so what do you do
when you get a bunch of different
peoples takes you come up with your own
but how do you do that I mean if did you
if you just came up with your own why
bother with listening to anybody yeah
I'm saying when you gather information
for all the people you come up with your
own life let's say I get your opinion
your opinion yeah I come up with like
you're on the right track keep going
what do you do with their opinions that
has to do with how high you come up with
your own
there's a reason why you care about
obviously 100 more than I do okay very
good so when you check out it what
everyone else has to say you may not
accept everything that they say you take
bits from this part where they're right
bits from this part or the right you
don't have to this we say reinvent the
wheel every time that it's the same way
in athletics people have been thinking
about this stuff for a very very long
time we don't have to come up with our
own new rate system of ethics we can see
what other people who said and if they
were right about something let's let's
take them let's make that our own that's
what Aristotle is going to do so I'll
see all of you monday have a good